[Music]
here today at Google cloud next
hopefully a good event for you so far
it's being fun
excellent excellent so Craig can you
tell me a little bit today about gke
hybrid orchestra yes of course with this
week launched the cloud services
platform which has a number of
components that make it possible to
build a hybrid infrastructure across
Google cloud and on-premises
environments we have gke on prem which
allows you to run gke managed by google
in your own data center we have sto 1.0
which allows us to build a hybrid
service mesh that connects the two
networks together and allows us to
seamlessly route traffic between the two
locations
excellent so when we interact with this
demo if I slide these back and forth
what what will we be creating with this
we're creating an orchestra that's the
metaphor we're using here and it's great
because we talked about orchestration
Reche Canyon and we have a piece of
music which we are pumping through in
MIDI format we're sending that out as
HTTP calls rest calls to our instrument
services mm-hmm when they are received
the music is tagged with the instrument
that it needs to be played and then
that's written to firebase we have those
instrument services running and
deployments in both our gke cluster and
GPA on print and then the wall you see
here is showing both the visualization
of the scale of the pods that are
required for the instrument so again if
our bassoon is playing has five units of
traffic we can see this five pursuance
here playing and you can also see and
hear the music and in this case you can
see the music is being redirected so all
the parts are being played by our
on-premises environment thankfully we
see the overlap of the colors as the
instrument music is being played as the
redirects are causing the music to be
played by those four instruments now
what you see here is a service which
runs on Google Cloud which generates
music and pushes it through various
instruments services that run
microservices cluster we have some of
those instruments running on Google
cloud in the same cluster as the
conductor that's making the music happen
and then we also have some of those
instruments deployed in our on-premises
environment using sto in its Multi
cluster mode we're able to connect those
two clusters together to the same
network control plane so we're able to
get traffic sent to services based on
the hostname and it doesn't matter if
that service is deployed in the cloud
cluster on gke or on-premise with GP on
Prem you can address that traffic and it
will be received by the right service
another great feature of Sto is to do
traffic routing which you might do to
test a new service by saying I'll deploy
the new service and direct the small
percentage of traffic to it and once I'm
comfortable that was no failures
gradually ramp that up over time until
I'm turning a hundred percent of my
traffic and then turn my old one off
what we have in this environment in
these little patch cords we're able to
say the music for the bassoon generally
the conductor will give that to the
bassoon player to play we have scale so
we can say if we send five parts of that
we need five bassoon players but we can
also use stos virtual services to say
instead of that music going to the
bassoon player let's have a little pixie
come and take that on the way and
intercept it and give it to the clarinet
player so now it says there are five
paths of traffic that need to be played
by the clarinet player scale the
clarinet up to five you don't need any
discerns so we can scale them back down
we can transparently redirect that
without the calling or the collie
application having to know anything
about what's happening I see and what
song is this Orchestra playing if you
don't recognize it this is the theme
from Tetris activities a and actually
it's a Russian folk song I believe from
the 1890s which again was made popular
in the 1990s some a nice bit of symmetry
there and a nice little bit of interplay
with the concept of kubernetes container
scheduling we've often used Tetris as a
metaphor for how we split all the pieces
into place excellent and what makes this
an interesting problem for us to be
solving here at next kubernetes has
become the API of choice for deploying
workloads especially workloads that are
containerized or things that can build
top of that metaphor and we have had GK
for some time it's been generally
available for three years now but if you
want to run it in your own data center
it's either take the open source parts
or take some third-party product which
generally embeds Camila's but isn't the
same as the GK environment it's they're
all conformance so we know that we'll
run the same workloads but the
management is different than versions in
the upgrade cycle you have to look at a
lot about your safety so first of all
the problem of running GK in your data
center can be solved by GK you can use
the same management console all of the
things are running here we can see on
the screen we have over here we're able
to see the workloads in a single pane of
glass cloud and on frame together the
second thing that's been complicated in
the past is mission these two things
together it's connecting these two
disparate networks so that just by
calling a hostname we don't need to care
whether the service is implemented by
this cluster or the one on friend we're
able just to say call the bassoon send
it to those pods it will be served
wherever they're running and indeed we
can change the split and move
instruments between the environments
excellent Craig thank you so much for
your time today and enjoy the last day
of the conference
[Music]